well amendment 64 passed overwhelmingly
in Colorado we got 55% of the vote
we got 50,000 more votes than Barack
Obama received in Colorado so marijuana
is more popular than Barack Obama the
president in our state our law firm was
formed in May 2010 to work on medical
marijuana issues it was formed right
after the law passed and then we started
writing the the language for the ballot
initiative that became amended
sixty-four really shortly thereafter
June July 2010 I was a framer of the
amendment 64 so I helped draft it
commented throughout the process and
then on the campaign I was a strong
supporter of it and then after the
campaign ended our law firm was the firm
that was retained to do the government
Relations for statutory and regulatory
implementation for the campaign some of
the supporters of amendment 64 have
created a coalition with many of the
opponents of 64 most notably Attorney
General John Suthers and governor john
hickenlooper both of whom campaigned
quite actively against 64 you know I
didn't think I'd be running another
statewide campaign with my friends a
year later the interesting part is that
it's our friends but it's also mostly
the people who said we don't want this
that are on our campaign team now not
quite the same chemistry as we used to
have I would say this community is
definitely not a monolith we have many
disagreements within our community you
know marijuana people are free thinkers
they don't they're not hurted together
when we don't all sing from the same
sheet of music which is a healthy thing
it's a diverse community and there are
those of us who are come down on the
side of freedom less government
individual rights I would put myself in
that camp and then there are others from
the more traditional progressive liberal
big government sort of mentality in our
movement and that's great we'll take
those votes I don't agree with them and
right now the issue is with taxation
it's taxed from when it's grown the
person who
there's a taxation event when it's
transferred to either the stores for
sale or to an infused products company
to make you know brownies other things
like that
that tax is set at 15% that was actually
the language of that that established
that was in the amendment the first
forty million dollars of that goes to
public school construction so that's
obviously less a lot less controversial
because it was already in the in the
language of the amendment the the more
controversial piece is the sales tax
that's set up to fifteen percent but it
starts at ten percent and that's on the
retail sale of marijuana alcohol
prohibition hurt everybody even even if
you had no intention of ever having a
drink in your life you were still harmed
by living in a society where alcohol was
prohibited so we were able to have that
argument that prohibition doesn't work
treat it like alcohol regulated like
alcohol
the problem is proposition a a which is
the tax increase and all these other
regulations don't regulate it like
alcohol what a lot of people don't know
and understand about what's happening is
they started it like 50 percent at the
legislative session we negotiated hemmed
and hawed you know we try to get it down
as low as possible we knew that there
was gonna be a need for some level of
Taxation to pay for regulations if we
were going to pay for our own system no
sort of that the trade-off for having
the state move forward and in a pretty
rapid in robust way amendment 64 allows
any adult 21 years old or older to grow
six plants in their home in a warehouse
I believe of 15 percent sales tax plus a
15 percent excise tax is too high the
consumer will quickly figure out that is
a tax that they don't have to pay and
they won't be willing to pay it and then
you then you bring the medical side into
it also medical marijuana will not be
taxed at that 15 plus 15 percent rate
and Coloradans will probably just not
participate so much in the recreational
market it'll become a tourist only thing
and it won't succeed yeah it's tough
it's controversial a lot of people that
supported us for 64 don't support us for
this so
the current regulations are extremely
burdensome I mean this industry is
regulated more tightly than any other
industry in Colorado examples in order
to own one of these entities you have to
be a two-year resident of our state the
residency requirement is the biggest
barrier that's the thing that keeps all
the money out that's the thing that
keeps evaluations of business down
there's also a complete moratorium on
any new shop statewide opening before
October 1st 2014 so what the state has
done is unwisely lock in the medical
marijuana industry and all the existing
players you know so I you know look I
agree I don't think that there that it's
appropriate to sort of like play
favorites more any more than the
amendment allows which it did talk about
participation in the medical industry
gives you a first option really to get
in it's a little bit more nuanced than
that but but that's in there you know
and we put that in there because these
people stuck their necks out does that
mean they should have five years or ten
years no and in Denver which is the
leader we have more dispensaries in
Denver than any other municipality in
our state the City Council has added two
years to the moratorium period for new
entries so October 2016 the industry was
trying to protect itself absolutely the
industry representatives in their
lobbyists that's what they were doing
but there are a lot of people also just
protecting the realm you know which is
which is to say that we were trying to
make sure that this thing did you just
blow up in our face you've got a hundred
thousand licensed patients in Colorado
that that is the sum total of the
consumer base you'll have six hundred
thousand regular marijuana consumers
once recreational marijuana comes
completely online and that's January 1st
of 2014 so these existing shops who
can't handle hundred thousand are
somehow going to be asked to handle six
hundred thousand they won't be able to
do it
the prices are already going to climb
because of supply and demand add taxes
to that so they've created the barriers
to entry of taxes prior felons two-year
residency again my insight 2020 you look
at what the Cole memo says and you're
like okay look that that that gives me
more comfort that we can move forward
does it give me complete comfort that we
should this is
widgets now and we can make as many as
we want and if there's overflow and you
know Oklahoma needs widgets we should
have them go down there
absolutely not like this is not a free
market it's just simply not as far as
tourism that's a conundrum you know when
you come to Colorado you ought to be
able to enjoy your constitutional rights
while you're here and and there was a
specific intent behind amendment 64 to
not just apply it to Colorado residents
and I'm a hundred percent for people
coming to Colorado and spending money
and renting rooms and going to our
restaurants and bars and everything else
but then the question is where do these
tourists smoke if they're staying in you
know a high-end hotel in Aspen Vail or
Denver most of these places are
non-smoking
you can't smoke it walking down the
street technically you're not supposed
to smoke on the lift in Vail if you can
if it's open in public but it's funny
you know you talk to the City Council
and other people there we don't want to
become the Amsterdam of America and I'm
like have you been to Amsterdam you know
like one of the crown jewels of Europe
you know yeah sure maybe you don't to be
the red-light district
in Amsterdam of America but why would
you not want people coming here and
bottom line is we we have to have
private smoking clubs we have to have a
place where both tourists and Colorado
residents can go congregate associate
with each other and enjoy their
constitutional rights together you know
I think it's it's really important that
we be responsible measured in our lap
you know but again the federal
government is getting less and less of a
concern because the people of this
country obviously think we need to go
different directions but we saw have a
long way to go anyone who's like overly
confident at this point this is like the
worst possible time to be overly
confident